That's hard for me to predict.
I know that this is a topic that to
Michael Claire and other people have
promoted as the idea that we're going to
fight over water,
oil,
a timber,
you name it.
Um,
what I see is a,
is a world becoming more interdependent
in everything.
My book,
the thesis of my book Gusher of lies is
really that the world is interdependent
in any number of commodities,
whether it's ipods or beer or fresh
flowers,
tennis shoes,
and that interdependence is going to
strengthen actually in the coming years
because we have no choice as different
companies.
I'm sorry,
it's different.
Countries become better at producing
certain commodities.
They will assert their influence in the
marketplace.
And my book debunks the idea that energy
independence as possible,
that it's doable or even desirable for
the US.
What we really need to be looking at is
interdependence.
Um,
and that is in fact what the market and
energy and other commodities has had
for,
for decades and will continue to have
there.
There clearly is a lot of,
uh,
of rhetoric about the issue of oil and
fighting over oil.
I think what I see in the future as
natural gas becomes a more critical
player in the global economy.
It is a,
I think,
much more of a bind necessity.
It is a much more cooperative.
Commercial enterprise pipelines require
a stronger connections between
countries,
uh,
and gas really is only effectively moved
in at the moment,
uh,
by gas pipeline.
We're going to see on an emerging gas
market that has global due to the
increasing use of liquified natural gas
and I think compressed natural gas,
which is not in the market yet,
uh,
in any significant degree,
at least in the marine market.
But I,
I,
I think I would argue the opposite.
That I think as the world gets a more
integrated,
as the market for energy gets more
I think that we're going to see a
further cooperation among countries
because it is in their commercial
interest.
And in fact,
if you look at what has happened with
the,
uh,
with your ran,
despite America's efforts to isolate the
Iranians,
what we are,
in fact seeing as the Iranians making
multiple commercial deals with numerous
countries around the world,
uh,
whether it's the Brazilians,
the Turks,
the Austrians,
the Iranians are integrating their
economy and their energy commodities
into the global economy and doing it
very effectively.